l'unico ma che ne facevo che devono
essere arrivato al kalak allora voi non
avete idea
voi non avete idea può scoperto
minecraft la prima volta nella mia vita
tipo sei anni fa
67 anni fa non mi ricordo andò ancora
quasi nessuno gioventù lava non ci
giocavo da un botto e ma in tutti questi
anni non ho mai fatto una cosa così
epica quindi ragazzi tenetevi pronti
perchè questo sarà l'episodio più epico
della vita
c'è uno che sta arrivando dall'alto
bastardo dotato st
io non lo posso prendere non le frecce
se adesso mi ha visto che stanno
tracciando dalla parte dove lo vedo gli
ha lanciato un nuovo una cosa bravo
pescara si può tenere le uova quanto
sono morte se le uova ragazzi l'arma del
mancano neanche 2 che magari con uno è
quello di prima che tornando a casa ma
anche in questo server book da una una
sfida in cui chi teletrasporta tutte le
stesse copritevi raga ma stia meno
freddo che offre occhio però occhio è
però non ho mai dato fk non si sta
muovendo tranquillo è talmente fermo è
bravo a fare questo papa la faccia di
lavoro fa la statua esatto poi ci
ammazza tutti e tre a che ora quando che
mai sparato una freccia che è successo
ma calogiuri ma è lì tu ca nun ce le
frecce caravano muore e non muore ok
morto a gravi c'è questa cosa era
addirittura anni aiace sei andata fk
perché non ce l'ha più voglia c'era
qualcuno che vi sparava frecce che
dovrebbe essere l'ultimo rimasto vivo ma
non capisco dov'è ma eccolo dubbi e
dietro riaguarda aspetta il tuo attuale
esatto quello che stai guardando
dall'alto caduca porca [ __ ] ma così
beccato ok
ah eccolo che aspetto prima di lancio
dell'uovo uova contro freccia ti faccio
vedere che le frecce non sono niente
spera gasol sull'isola giusta no sei
sull'altra isola
siete dei pirla mamma mia si sta
lanciando palle di neve ha colpito nella
direzione giusta raga salite su quel
cazzo di albero e frecciate lo dalla
prima mi vedete a lato mi vedete se
veramente spara a me e sparate a lui ma
io posso raccogliere se freccia non lo
sapevo ma come cazzo ma bellissimo
allora sì che lo ammazzo subito non mi
stai guardando mi stai guardando sta
distraendo avete ucciso eh no l'ho
colpito e basta altri blocchi loro siti
in via milli dio non ho visto sei forte
invito che è stato sasha bravo sasha
nicchia tu sì che se ne che ne sai
tavolo se c'erano i vecchi non dicevano
che loro avrebbero fatto meglio a tutto
qua ci sono i complimenti abbassavano il
cappello vedi cosa c'è scritto su questa
scritta qua qua sopra c'è scritto che
quelli bravi possono accompagnare solo
sono andato team 7 veloci ok ci siamo ci
sono venite qua e guardati e brutto
quelli che entrano nella loro vita dei
ragazzi siamo talmente qui potremo fare
una canzone rap tipo 7 su ogni cosa
eccola qui farò la gang strozzi e così
prima che abbia ammazzato dram sticks
davvero poverino per questa partita
allaga dobbiamo fare il corretto difesa
per vincere se vicoletto il signore la
e con lui non tremo più
la certezza la certezza è qui con me to
make up per star bene e abbiamo floriana
in squadra con noi
gloriana quella del grande fratello
ragazzi non spaccare tutto qua chiudere
gli alberi bruciare a terra tremare
avere tutto cadere mi chiare pare
floriana ha rubato le scarpe molto ci
vede che donna questa è mia e mi a
bastardo e mia prende tutte ma bastardo
mai curato la lava è che ho solo due
frecce allora chiedendo un po trash
amilcar ok niemela più incontro ad aiuti
da una prova di neve grazie che trade
cavolo mi che credi vi conviene
tantissimo guardano come vuole quello è
lo so se vai in parlamento ma non ha
preso l'acqua non ha colpito lo capite
che hanno dato moltissimo a tutti e due
minchia 2 in 1 collateral l'agar agar
agar venite tutti da me che facciamo un
assedio state guardando no perché c'è
nessuno per ora lo sai che ti stanno
pescando ma perché è ancora al
guinzaglio
portiamo animali senza mai un occhiale
arkia largo venga qualche altro venga
qua io non offre giocatori pesca questo
vieni corri corri carissimo
ecco mi dice sai dove dove lo vedi quel
ponte laggiù che ti vedi guarda guarda e
mi chiama anche se fossi buy su stiamo
bene mara vai su sto con te spara perché
ciò detto mi piacerebbe riavere arrivato
lo prendo lo prendo non ha fatto sta che
ha fatto sesta è scappato è scappato sta
che è fatto sta in questo evento ci
stava benissimo
io sono riuscito a recuperare due tre
frecce quindi io ho con tanti blocchi
per un ponte bello fra che c'è uno che
si stanno imitando adesso la nostra
isola mura amiche ma dai mi risulta
gratissimo con l'ho visto quella che mi
butto lo ammazzo ti butto lo ammazzo
noto di l'acconto di l'acqua o colpito
l'ho colpito alla mazzo io e morte molte
ma la madonna valigia che ospita la king
come rovinare un attacco kamikaze di
sarri io l'avevo detto che non era vuota
l'isola sto bastardo segreti state così
era un tronco tronco di fedaia
basta chi è stato tagliato loro addio
saltati mimetizzati o no
cazzo ma sono i fenomeni questi non si
potesse mimetizzare la gente ma quanto
figo ha colpito dove dov'è e suppone
restando sul ponte sul po sta scappando
subito il giusto
bravo tegra ucciso istituto sori in
teoria si immagina di castigo ai
vietcong dei cani e quindi minecraft
cos'è ma questi hanno vissuto veramente
la guerra rally che si stavano mangiando
le braccia per sopravvivere per
sopravvivere
no ragazzi amo sicuri che l'isola è
libera adesso metà gara ma solo a marzo
1 ragano più di uno non è uno solo non
l'ho colpito dai e io sono sull'altra
isola porcava manca pochissimo avevo
colpito porco demonio ma è quello sul
ponte se ci sono due frutto andato
vicino alla morte quest'uomo
il rischio ragazzo punto vado io
direttamente sul loro contributo live a
usare la prova a fare il ninja ucciderli
dai tutto per tutto e tutto e per tutto
però stata l'andar da solo sonore minimo
di nemmeno ormai ci sono sono lanciato
ecco li rivedo livello livello li vedo
li ho visti no nasce dell'acqua è stato
prima se mi dici dove siedono acqua
acqua ne ha ucciso uno figlio di [ __ ]
ho capito di punto tutto preso dai crepa
11 ucciso storici sotto cazzo hai ha
ucciso ucciso
stavo bravo sì io vi ho perso giusto
così siamo rimasti nell'isola che
stavano ammazzando uno della madonna
raga non crepano come faccio ucciderne
uno non credo allora che lo pacchetto
avevo la skin come le foglie degli
alberi e quell'altra non trovata uccisa
cioè se ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta io
sia rimasto in un team da 54 al nostro
centro allora è lui siete al centro come
cazzo arrivo io c'entro e oggi non di
vista evitato di ritornare nell'isola
dove eravamo prima e bella bona c
no no logico raccolte qua guarda c'è un
ponte già fatto mi trasferito su st
isola io sono dalla parte opposta mi sa
sono dalla parte opposta vostra spazio
penso dovremmo fare adesso per della
domanda
giro io sono dalla parte opposta posso
prenderli da dietro immagino un po no
finché noi non abbiamo il punto grazie
per la freccia che finché non abbiamo il
punto è finito non saltarli dietro si
chiede ovvero politico ok è salito sul
ponte amico a rompergli il cazzo e direi
arrivo arrivo arrivano mai
ha giocato cassonato caso la donna ha
avuta non ce l'ho 6 arrivando qui cari
carica dai dai dai
ma che mi fregio che nei precedenti su
rivas che marcava più elevate bastardi
crepate crepa credo le pagine cazzo
madonna che che caspita che tattica a
masi
cazzo siete fantastici
no no che cosa ti avevo detto appena
loro ci attaccano arriviamo che non si
aspettavano mai mamma bravissimi ragazzi
menti partita della vita bellissimo
porca eva porca cosa fa nuova bei
ragazzi allora io ho passato metà
partita
l'ultima a cercare di aggirare tutti i
quattro deficienti all'api e ci sono
riuscito è incredibile ammazzati 800
sono gladiatore è stato veramente
assurdo e ringrazio comunque il mio team
di gladiatori fortissimi che senza gli
oro comunque non ci sarei riuscito
perché loro hanno distratto tutti quanti
nel mentre che io facevo questa epica
mossa in gioco di squadra ragazzi gioco
di squadra e quindi ragazzuoli sparò in
questo video vi sia piaciuto kuga
schermo dite che non so giocare sa mai
cosa del ragazzino mi piaceva anche i
vari social che come l'invito a catena
iscrizione generati dischetti di ci
vediamo un prossimo vito brena ragazzi